Well if we go too far to the left, it means that we're going to have poor peak performance
because we'll be using the slower thread per element approach on
data that would instead be a better fit for the faster thread per row approach.
But if we go too far to the right, then we'll be using thread per row on
irregular row lengths, and that's going to lead to poor load balance.
Bell and Garland noted that thread per row is about 3 times faster than thread per
element for matrices with balanced rows.
So their rule of thumb for drawing the line was
when 1/3 of the rows have non-zero elements--simple and sensible.
You'll find their approach called hybrid, an NVIDIA cuSPARSE, sparse matrix library.